>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Edward Widmer: Hi
everyone, welcome.
I have the same document printed
out twice in different point sizes
because -- my -- ever since
I started wearing glasses,
my eyesight has just gotten so bad.
Before I forget, I want to say,
especially on a beautiful day
like this, why not go to a dark
establishment, whoever wants to go,
let's have one of our readings
tune in the Kluge Annex just
down Pennsylvania Avenue.
It's a great pleasure to
introduce our friend to all of us,
Shaden Tageldin, who is Associate
Professor of Cultural Studies
and Comparative Literature in the
Department of Cultural Studies
and Comparative Literature at
the University of Minnesota,
where she is also the director of
the African Studies Initiative,
a title VI African Studies
National Resource Center,
funded by the U.S.
Department of Education.
From 2013 to 2015, she was
director of graduate studies
in that department as well
as for the Interdepartmental
Graduate in Moving Image Studies.
She is the recipient of the 2014 to
2014 Motley Exemplary Teaching Award
from the College of Liberal Arts.
In her teachings, she focuses on
19th and 20th century literature
in English, Arabic and French.
Her research engages several
fields within a transnational
and a translingual compass
empire and postcolonial studies,
critical translation
theory, trans-African
and trans-Asian studies, the
historiography of literary
and cultural renaissance, the
politics of idealogy of language,
literary form and literary
genre, and literatures
of migration and diaspora.
She earned a PhD in comparative
literature from UC Berkley in 2004.
Her first book, "Disarming
Words: Empire and the Seductions
of Translation in Egypt" came out
with University of California Press
in 2011 and received
honorable mention
for the 2013 Harry Levine prize
of the American Comparative
Literature of Association.
He was an old professor
of mine in Harvard
and her doctoral dissertation
won the ACLA's 2005 Charles
Bernheimer prize.
She's currently here as a Frederick
Berthark [phonetically spelled]
residential fellow and
she is writing a new book,
provisionally titled, "Toward
a Transcontinental Theory
of Modern Comparative
Literature," and that is the title
of today's talk, so
please welcome Shaden.
Thank you.
>> Shadon Tageldin:
Thank you very much,
Ted for that kind introduction.
Good afternoon, everyone and
thank you very much for coming
on this lovely Tuesday afternoon.
It is a great honor
and pleasure to speak
at the Library of Congress today.
I've been fortunate indeed to spend
this academic year in residency here
at the library's Kluge
Center as an American Council
of Learned Society's
Burkhardt Fellow.
Few research centers offer an
environment as warm, collegial,
productive, and, yes, provocative
for thinking with others
in different disciplines,
changes the questions you ask,
the sources you explore
and the answers you find.
I would like to thank Ted Widmer,
Mary Louriker [phonetically
spelled], Travis Hensley,
Dan Torrelo, Anastasia
Jones, Kaley Mosley Jackson,
former Kluge staff members, Joanne
Kitchins [phonetically spelled],
and Denise Robinson, yes, I had
to name everyone as well as each
and everyone of the Kluge
fellows I have met and engaged
over the past nine months for
making my time here such a pleasure.
Finally, I warmly thank Dr. Fossey
[phonetically spelled] Tethorus
[phonetically spelled] and
his colleagues in the African
and Middle Eastern reading,
as well as Eric Frasier
and [inaudible] Ashmen [phonetically
spelled] and Rare Books
and Special Collections
for their assistance
in locating research
material, which is ongoing.
I also thank Cheryl Adams
in the main reading room,
Erica Spencer in the
European Reading Room
and Dr. Tomoka Finne [phonetically
spelled] in the Science Reading Room
for their assistance at various
points in my research thus far.
The title of my lecture
today, once again,
is "Toward a Transcontinental Theory
of Modern Comparative Literature."
Taking the case of
Arabic English and French
from the late 18th century
through the early 20th,
my lecture is today is
part of a book in progress
that traces the rise of
modern comparative literature
to a new global regime in
which a language acquired power
in the world empire in so far
as it held the power to observe
and to capture the world
exactly in empiricism.
In the shadow of imperialism and in
empiricism, languages like Arabic
that once had styled themselves
incomparable, larger than life,
now were urged to point
unambiguously to all that they name,
to simulate life, the really
seen and really heard.
This term from artificial
to natural literary language
as newly bound-ward to world, making
incomparable languages comparable,
comparable that is in
their newly shared sense
that words should be life-like.
In this determination of
life, language was conceived
in increasingly smaller, we
might say, molecular units.
For the British orientalist,
Sir Williams Jones,
literatures could be made
comparable only by breaking down
and translating their
literatures or their languages
into lowest common denominators,
plain spoken words, shun of ornament
or particularizing styles and
sounds softened of all foreignness.
Indeed the word denominator
was not low or common enough,
comparison with demand at
times and even freer radical.
For French orientalist,
like [inaudible]
and Ernesto Renov [phonetically
spelled],
the life of a language has its
majority, has its comparability,
hedged on whether or not its
vowels were written seen.
For Egyptian and Syro-Lebanese
intellectuals like Abdul Nadeem
and Amin Shamil [phonetically
spelled] on whether
or not its cosmonauts translated
were heard across time and space.
The epistemic conditions
of possibility
that ground modern comparative
literature then demanded
that the world's diverse language
be comparable to the letter.
Not only must the graphing,
written signs and phoning sounds
of those languages be
mutually intelligible,
but so too the very relation,
the very understanding
of what the proper
connection between a graphing,
a written to a phoning
sound should be.
Even today, comparative literature
ascribes its disciplinary origins
to Europe and the United States,
often eliding develops elsewhere
at the theoretical level.
I ask by revisiting this share,
yet occluded history of language
and life, can we develop
a transcontinental theory
of modern comparative literature?
Before his conscription into
the ranks of imperial government
in Bengal and into imperial
views of the relationships
between the world's
languages and literature,
the young British orientalist,
William Jones,
not yet Sir William Jones,
understood that literary comparison
called on its practitioner to see
with other eyes and to
hear with other ears.
That is not to assume that the
real or the knowable world ended
with the seen and the heard, not to
misapprehend the unknown, unfamiliar
or invisible world as unreal, or
worse as inferior to one's own.
Jones opens his [foreign language]
dissertation on oriental literature
and the title page is up
here, written in French
and published anonymously
in London in 1717
with a counter-factual
parable, a cautionary what
if that marvelously inverts European
imperial perception and I quote,
"A king of [inaudible]," a present
day [inaudible] "could not imagine
that there could in the world
another kingdom than his own.
He had in truth heard
word of a race of animals
that inhibited the oxidants,
but he had never seen them.
For it meant nothing that
Louis XIV had sent missionaries
with the singular proposition that
he abolish the cult of his ancestors
and believe mysteries
despite himself.
His courtier told him that that race
was nothing but a race of monkeys.
His priest added that it was
not capable of the metamorphosis
of the great Funchiham
[phonetically spelled]
and his philosophers
assured him that,
according to very ancient
traditions, each inhabitant
of this barbaric country
had only one eye
in the center of the forehead.
The king having, as he must,
lent faith to these discourses.
It since had become a
fundamental dogma of the siamese
that occidentals only had one eye.
We are, with respect to the
orientals, in nearly the situation
that the inhabitants of Siam
are with respect to ours.
If the little that we know of their
visage prevents us from saying
that they have only one eye, we do
worse for we deny taste and soul."
To read literature comparatively,
Jones suggest, across languages
and cultures, one needs
the consciousness,
if you will pardon the
pun, a siamese twin.
The ability to apprehend
one's prejudices, today,
we might say racism and the limits
of one's knowledge by watching
or listening to oneself being
watched or overheard by another,
in this case by seeing the west
represented and hearing play back
through the eyes, ears
and voice a fictional
or fictional lies, King of Siam.
Comparativeness is the
critical recognition
that what you cannot see, cannot
hear and do not know, nonetheless,
exist apart from you and is
worth knowing on its own terms
and with awareness also of the self.
Notice that I do not
say what you do not see
and do not know and do not hear.
Jones tells us that it does
matter to the king of Siam
that he actually has seen
occidentals, the Jesuit missionaries
who have visited his
kingdom if one by seeing,
one means sense perception.
He has seen these beings
but cannot see them
or the foreign peoples
they represent
for the human beings they
are for his mind's eye,
sight beyond sense perception,
conceives these foreigners
as nonhuman animals, as
monkeys, and thus so on the basis
of the discourse to which it is
routinely exposed, what courtiers,
priests and philosophers say.
Saying trumps seeing,
rationalism, what the mind conceives
on its own, trumps empiricism.
I speak of this remarkable
passage as the opening
of Jones' [foreign
language] yet even before
that opening the book's epigraph
invents the 18th century western
reader to relocate the very
impulses of exploration
and comparative knowledge from
Europe to other continents.
It is a pronouncement in
Arabic, as you will see
on the slide, [foreign language].
Jones translates, "Seek
knowledge be it in China."
Later, Jones identifies
the prophet, Muhammad,
as the author of that pronouncement,
arguing that it proves "that letters
and fine arts are held on the
greatest esteem by the orientals."
The statement is a well-known
hatidith [phonetically spelled]
or the saying of the prophet whose
earliest followers in the 6th
to early 7th century Arabia,
China would have marked the
limit of the known world.
If one orient, Siam, sets the
stage for counterfactual parable
that unmasks the dangers
of Eurocentrism
and of all intellectual
absolutism, another orient, Islam,
moderns for Jones anecdote
to absolutist thinking,
the quest for knowledge
beyond one's sight and hearing
and thus the project and the
profit of comparison itself.
Even though Muhammad here only
speaks of China metaphorically,
writes Jones later in text,
we might hear it literally
for we are persuaded that
Chinese literature is
as useful as it is interesting.
Still, in invoking the
orient as a possible model
for comparative knowledge, Jones
consigns Arabic Islamic comparative
to metaphor, to figurative
language, to saying.
Seeing is the province of the
European, who is able to conceive
of China literally to the letter.
The orient may model an idea but
the occident is poised to put
that idea to empirical test.
I quote from Jones, "Those who do
not know the languages of orientals,
make incompetent judges of their
poetry but here is an experiment,"
and his term is [foreign language]
"that would obviate that error,
which one advises you to try,
that one would two odes,"
and here he shifts to another
orient, "one Arabic or Persian,
the other Greek or Latin,
translate these almost word for word
in a language of common
use with no ornament
or disguise grant what is due
to the diversity of idioms,
places and customs
of both sides equally
and that then one would
pronounce without prejudice
between the productions
of orientals and the works
that we admire everyday."
Presaging contemporary U.S.
comparativists like Gayatri Spivaka
and Emily After [phonetically
spelled]
who see language acquisition as
key to a comparative literature
that shuns the world dominance of
English, Jones argues that those
who do not know oriental languages
cannot judge their literatures.
Yet he proposes a work around
that permits such judgment,
one that depends, in fact, on
translation into a third language,
a language of common, [foreign
language], known both to writer
and reader and moreover to the
plainest form of that language,
a linguist and stylistic
lowest common denominator.
To make two literatures comparable,
Jones tells us, the scholar must,
in affect, sheer away all
ornaments, all markers of style,
which he associates not only with
excess but also with disguise
and translate both
literatures nearly word for word
into the plainest prose one can.
Then one can judge, he
says, then one can compare.
This experiment reconverts
comparison into an act
of empirical observation and
Baconian induction or generalization
from observed particulars even
if they are reduced particulars.
For if poems from two
different languages
and literary traditions can be
translated into a third language
of common use, their
features, supposedly,
will be more easily discernible
to the naked European eye and ear.
Jones proceeds to illustrate
his method.
To bring an alien orient into
comparison with a familiar west,
he translates two odes,
one from Persian by Hafez,
the other from Latin by Horace
and [inaudible] opposes these.
Having done so, he
conceives that the reader
who does not know the
original expressions
and the literary traditions
of these poems will fail
to grasp the felicity
of their expressions
and the elegance of their illusions.
Yet he insists that any such reader
can look at Hafez and Horace,
reduced to plain to French,
and decide ultimately
which of the two odes is the more
poetic, a quality he premises on,
what he calls, charming simplicity.
While he says that it is not up to
him to decide, he drops heavy hints
in favor of the Persian,
but when the comparativist
or translator breaks language
down into, what we might call,
molecular units, hear
words, where does style go.
Jones wants the European reader to
hear the music of oriental poetry,
yet translation pressed into
the service of comparison,
what it would seem, reduce
the unique musical phrasing
of the Persian and the Latin
respectively to mere strings
of common simplified,
de-contextualized notes
more readily exchangeable.
To demonstrate the aesthetic
value of oriental literatures
to the European reader, Jones
ultimately must prove the soundness
in all senses of their
languages, that is the sounds
of those languages are
melodious enough to merit
and justify the name poetry.
Translating the sense of the Persian
into common French words is
not adequate to that task.
Thus Jones goes onto
transliterate into Roman characters,
the Persian ode by Hafez that he
has just translated and placed
in comparison with the
Latin ode by Horace.
What is striking here is the apology
that follows this transliteration
and I quote from Jones, "Although
one should only judge the sweetness
of the language by the ear,
we fear that the majority
of readers were appreciated by the
eye and that they will be put off
by the frequency of consonants and
of hard letters [foreign language]
that they will there, but the organ,
i.e., the tongue articulates the
"huz" as easily as it
does any other consonant.
It is the Tuscan pronunciation of
'ch and of 'c' in the word, 'cavalo,
which has something
very gentle about it
when it is not too affected."
Thus the Persian "kh," it's
transliterated as "kh,"
which appears once
in the word, "khulk,"
which in Arabic means temperament,
in the transliterated ode,
is assimilated to the Tuscan "ch"
or hard "c" like the "c" in cavolo,
where it's not a "ch," but it's an
attempt to render the sound "ch."
From common sense and
sensibility, we enter the province
of common sound, the
comparison of letters.
Literature, is rooted
here in the letter,
a common denominator more radical
than the word, a written character
or grapheme, who shared spoken
or forcibly shared spoken
or phoneme the European
reader is invited to hear.
With his turn to the speech of
Tuscany, the dialect of Dante,
to bring the literatures of the
Arabic- Islamic orient to life
for the European reader, Jones
inaugurates, perhaps in spite
of himself, a new tendency
in the discourse
of European literary comparison.
That tendency would
replace orient with occident
as its fundamental model.
In comparative literature 1886, the
first English language monograph
to explicitly articulate
the nature and the method
of the modern discipline, the
Irish barrister and classist,
Hutchinson McCauley Pasnet
[phonetically spelled] traced the
root of comparative literary method
to Dante's De vulgari Eloquentia
on "Eloquence in the Vernacular,"
written between 1302 and 1305,
which argued that the time had come
for the spoken dialect of Tuscany
to [inaudible] with,
if not suppliant,
Latin as a language of writing.
And here I show you the particular
edition that happens to be
in the Rare Books Collection
of the Library of Congress.
There are many such editions, of
course, in libraries elsewhere
but this one was owned by Walt
Whitman and there is a little card
from I think the old card
catalog, or replica thereof,
which shows that Walt Whitman
listed the half title pages,
listed all of the pages where his
name appeared in Pasnet's study
of comparative literature, so our
typical egocentrism is at work.
You will see that volume was part of
an international scientific series,
which is interesting in terms of the
placement of comparative literature
in the modern 19th century sciences.
So I quote now from Pasnet from the
relevant passage, where he speaks
of Dante's De Vulgari Eloquentia."
"When Dante wrote the "Eloquial
Vulgari, this is Pasnet's reference,
it's usually called either,
"De Vulgari Eloquial,"
or "De Vulgari Eloquentia," he
marked the starting the point
of our modern comparative
science, the nature of language,
a problem not be lightly overlooked
by the peoples of modern Europe,
inheriting unlike Greek or
Hebrew, a literature written
in a tongue whose decomposition had
plainly gone to make up the elements
of their own living speech.
The Latin, followed at an
interval by the Greek renaissance,
laid the foundations of
comparative reflection
in the mind of modern Europe."
Pasnet rightly identifies the nature
of language a key starting point
of modern comparative literature,
yet not just any language;
for Pasnet invokes as a key
force that throws language
and literature open to comparative
reflection as he calls it "The rise
of modern Italian or French,"
once spoken variance of Latin,
the written lingual Franca of
western Europe as languages
of writing in their own right.
Thus a particular register
of language, the vernacular,
grounds the literature
that comes to be defined
as the proper object
of modern comparison.
To enter the zone of the modern
comparison, as Pasnet defines it,
it seems, a literature must be
living speech, realized in writing.
In the language of a comparable
literature, death can only survive
if it is an intrinsic part of life.
Death must be transmuted into dying,
decomposition and it must also,
in being so transmuted, reconstitute
the living in perpetuity.
Forms of language that precede
and exceed living speech
suddenly seem a waste of breath.
It is not that language is
inassimilable to living speech,
don't breath; they do even
their respirations are
sometimes unvocalized.
In this regime of the
modern of comparison
of literature, they can't breath.
They're not allowed to breath.
I turn the page now
one century earlier
to Vulni's [phonetically spelled]
"Simplicacion de [inaudible]
oriental," "Simplification
of oriental languages," published
in Paris in 1795, a text that,
as I have also learned in
the Rare Books collection
of the library Thomas Jefferson
once owned and Jefferson, in fact,
owned many works by the [inaudible]
Vulni who voyaged, in fact, to Egypt
and Sierra in the 1780s
and writes another text
on that series of travel.
In addition to the
rise of the vernacular,
Pasnet noted the European
discovery of the new world
as a decisive element
in the emergence
of modern comparative sensibility;
yet in Vulni's estimation,
Europe did not need to voyage
so far away to discover the sort
of radical difference that
awakens the impulse of comparison.
It's familiar.
The Arabic-Islamic
world was, in many ways,
its most radically foreign.
A dividing line of contrast has
stubbornly persevered, Vulni writes,
"For many centuries
between the Asiatics,
above all the Arabs
and European peoples.
We are separated by only 60 nautical
hours from Algeria and from Tunis,
just 14 days take us to
Egypt, to Syria, to Greece,
18 to Constantinople
and yet one would say
that these peoples inhabit another
planet that, though contemporaries,
we live separated by
several centuries.
The crude observer,
Luvir [phonetically spelled] Kharf
[phonetically spelled] is content
to see as the reason for these
contrasts, the difference
between religions, [inaudible]
customs, but this difference,
itself, has its causes and one finds
that the most powerful, indeed,
perhaps the only such cause,
consists of the difference
of languages."
End of quote.
While various points in the
Ottoman empire are within short sail
from Europe and all seem on the
surface temporarily proximate,
[foreign language], contemporaries,
they are to borrow the phrase
of Johanna Fabian in
"Time and the Other,"
denied co-evilness with Europe.
They're not allowed to occupy the
same time, the same chronology.
The most spatially proximate is
the most historically distant,
separated by centuries and the
historical gulf between is measured
and fathomed in through and as
language in the nautical mile
of a vernacular vision of language.
And I quote again from Vulni, "I
account for little the contrast
and the movement of Arabic script,
which while we trace our lines
from left to right, traces its own
from right to left and begins a book
where we finish it, but a third
difficulty, the most serious,
the most radical, is its
alphabetic system, itself.
It is the incomplete,
indeed, perverted,"
the word used here is
[foreign language],
which has a strong moral
cast, "indeed perverted manner
in which Arabic depicts
the spoken word,"
and the phrase is [foreign
language].
In our languages of Europe, every
element of that word, vowel,
consonant, aspiration, all is
painted or depicted with detail,
precision, scruple and clear
images pass through to the minds.
We even regard a language as
all the more perfect in so far
as its script more exactly paints
or depicts all of its pronunciation
as that language is
written as it is pronounced.
By contrast, Arabic and its
analogue, [inaudible], Persian,
Turkish, not only does one
not write as one speaks
but one writes really half
of one's words in the main,
only consonants are outlined,
which are its principle base
and the four long vowels depicted in
the alphabet, the three short vowels
that played a greatest
role in pronunciation
and that are an integral thereof
are suppressed and implied.
One must supply these from
imagination and do so impromptu."
End of quote.
What makes Arabic and its
users so radically different
from the languages of Europe
and their users, Vulni suggests,
is incomplete and even perverted
binding of letter of written sign,
grapheme, to sound phoning to
image and ultimately also to sense.
Arabic writing, so goes the
charge, does not depict spoken words
or does not paint them with
sufficient faithfulness
to the sounds they
ostensibly must recall
or to the images they
ostensibly must conjure forth.
In such a system, enunciation
is not simply a question
of [foreign language],
taking the floor, you know,
launching the spoken word,
it is rather a question
of [foreign language], painting
or depicting the spoken word.
And to the extent that the writer
of Arabic writes only half words,
he or she eats them, no longer able
in Vulni's judgment to communicate
and thereby to enter the sphere
of positive comparability.
Failing to mark in most
cases the short vowels
that would make its rendering in
script fully identical to sound,
fully representative and
transparent, calling on its reader
to supply sound from silence, to
fill in the blanks, swirling above
and below the lines of text from
the realtime reservoir of his
or her imagination to
bring voice to mute speech,
Arabic enters this French regime
of comparison as defective
and defects from this world.
Vulni's argument inflicts Ernest
Raunak [phonetically spelled]
reading of written versus
dialectal or spoken Arabic
in his [inaudible] historic general
system compare [foreign language],
general history of
and comparative system
of Semitic languages
first published in 1855.
Here, as in Vulni, the absence
of presence of the vowel
in Arabic letters marks
an opposition of the death
of Semitic languages
to the contrasting life
of their endo-European counterparts.
I quote from Raunak, "The
habit of not writing vowels,
thereby effacing the subtle nuances,
in which adheres all individuality
of the dialect, reduces Semitic
text to a sort of skeleton,
excellent for the anatomical study
of language but hardly proper
to the study of movement
and of life.
In a language that is not life
for [inaudible] is not
historical and not comparable.
Languages must be compared," he
writes, "to living beings of nature.
Their life, like that of man and
humanity, is a perpetual becoming."
What emerges as an opposition
of endo-European languages,
which occupy a distinctly Hegelian
state of perpetual becoming
and are thus living
because historically,
historically because
living to Semitic languages.
These languages, Arabic
in particular are dead,
because in [inaudible] invocation of
terms that the German philosopher,
Hegel, infamous reserved for Africa,
they "no longer have a
history," [foreign language].
Dubbing Arabic, the last
survivor and "soul representative
of Semitism," an interesting
statement in itself, Raunak sees it
as absolutely unique the
incomparable distillation, summation
and perfection of a family of
languages whose lives have ended,
"written without the slightest
nuance of dialect," Arabic
and other Semitic languages
are fixed in what he calls,
"a metallic rigidity that blocks
all developed interior life.
Compared with Endo-European
languages, so essentially vegetal
and living," Raunak, writes, "Arabic
and its kin are inorganic
and mineral.
Everywhere," he writes, "an
ancient language gives way
to a vernacular [foreign language],
modern dialect corresponding
to a progression of analysis,
clearer more explicit,
separately that which the ancient
assembled, breaking the mechanisms
of the former language
to grant to each idea
and to each relation its
isolated expression."
"Formal Arabic," Raunak
suggests, " is an exception.
It has not evolved toward the
modern dialect, the vernacular.
Arabic is in a word 'o compose.'
Failing to decompose, as vegetal
life does, into isolated fragments,
Arabic and its Semitic cousins
supposedly have not followed the
natural way of language toward
simplification but held fast
for a problematic complexity,
read artificiality."
And I quote again from Raunak,
"This ancient of decomposition
is entirely missing
from Semitic languages.
No a single letter has been lost.
Guarded by closed and
precise mouths,
they have very rarely
fallen in jargon.
The three fundamental articulations
of each root have remained a sort
of bone structure that has
preserved them from all softening.
The Semitic script system
for its part has contributed
in no small part to this
phenomenon of persistence.
One cannot say that
Semites write in a manner
as perfect as the Endo-Europeans.
They represent only
the skeleton of words.
They render the idea
rather than the sound.
Latin and Italian, written
after the Semitic manner,
would hardly differ one from
the other but one cannot deny
that this writing, so
inconvenient to the foreigner,
has not been excellent for
the conservation of roots.
It has maintained the root as a
sort of perfectly pure diamond
across all grammatical accidents."
Both the letter and
usually trilateral root
of formal Semitic languages
jealously guarded
by the essentially closed
mouths of its speakers
and by extension equally mute pens
of its writers not only do not
change but also do not sound.
As bone structure skeleton,
perfectly pure diamond,
Arabic and related
languages are mineral
in Raunak's most charitable
reading, precious mineral, yet dead,
nonetheless, in their
immunity to alteration.
Rather than going the
way of Latin to Italian
and undergoing the decomposition
associated with living speech
as Pasnet too later would
suggest the language
of comparable literature
must, they have fossilized.
For Vulni and Raunak, Arabic is
[inaudible] wants limitless test
and the limit of comparison
for the sciences
of the European long 19th century.
Arabic letter, in every sense
of that term, spell the fate
of what enters the
sphere of comparison
and what lies beyond its pail.
This too is true for
the modern discipline
of comparative literature.
I return to Pasnet.
In so far as Pasnet's roots,
modern comparative literary method,
as we have seen, in the rise
of the vernaculars in Europe,
and insist in turn that that
method must be historical,
the degree to which a
written language coincides
with its spoken form signals its
historicity and comparability.
Small wonder then that he invokes
the Arabic-Islamic literary
tradition as the avatar of
incomparability and I quote,
"If we are determined to lay down
the dogma that Shakespeare or Dante
or any other poet wrote above
space and time, above the social
and physical conditions
under which he lived,
we really exclude historical
propriety by a creed
of literary inspiration, which
has been frequently asserted,
if not believed in, with
theological insurance.
We imitate the criticism of the
Arabs and make a literary croon
out of our Shakespeare or Dante."
The literary croon is Pasnet's
metaphor for the transformation
of Shakespeare and Dante by the
western critics who canonized them
into incomparable divinities
whose ambit is universal
and timeless rather
than historically grounded
in place and time.
"Those critic methods," he argues,
and I quote, "it's almost as fatal
to true historical science as the
Muslim belief that the language
and ideas of their Bible came
direct from God, himself."
The entanglement of the doctrine
of the inevitability of the Quran
with the incomparability
of its language, Arabic,
is now a kind of shorthand
for a theological impulse
that must be banished epistemic
sites of comparative literature,
which must be true to
historical science.
Paradoxically, Shakespeare
and Dante are often divinities
of this new historical
scientific literary order.
Marshalls tightened the umbilical
cord between the vernacular
and the rise of modern properly
comparable European literature.
It is thus in the negative as
that which is deemed incomparable,
uniquely defective in its
other worldly perfection
by most western scholars
and increasingly
over the imperial course of the
long 19th century in complex ways
by Arabic speaking intellectuals
that Arabic enters a
transcontinental theory
of modern comparative literature.
Together, they would ask, what kind
of language forms a properly modern
and worldly Arabic literature?
Writing in 1893, in the
Kirov [phonetically spelled]
of [inaudible], Sir William
Wilcox called on Egyptians
to shed formal written Arabic
[foreign language] a reportedly
artificial dead language,
he calls it such,
and to write in the vernacular
colloquial Amia instead.
Lack of natural, embedded, living
literary language, he [inaudible],
stymies the originality that
drives scientific invention,
hence [inaudible].
An Anglo-Indian engineer,
Wilcox arrived in Egypt in 1883,
one year after the
British occupation.
He redesigned Egypt's irrigation
system and as director general
of reservoirs, designed and
supervised the construction
of the first Le Swan dam
between 1896 and 1902.
Wilcox maintained that just
as British engineering had freed the
Egyptian peasant from force labor,
so too would British promotion
of Egyptian Arabic unshackle
the Egyptian intellectual
from coercive artifices.
Indeed, his first paper
on the language, itself,
delivered in formal Arabic.
It was delivered before a Egyptian
club and this is a printed text,
transcript, of the talk,
"Argued that modern Egyptians had
lost the scientific creativity they
had possessed in ancient
time because 'the authors
of their scientific secular books
write language hard as rock,
literally like mountain," and "set
down thoughts and books to die,
never to return to life as if
they are attuning them in page
and burying them between
the covers of books."
Contrast English with the rise of
vernacular English, Wilcox argues,
came not only the works of
the celebrated English poet,
Shakespeare, but also those of
Sir Francis Bacon, who he writes,
"pend the lessons to which the
European sciences owe their
first appearance.
In June 1893, in the same journal
[inaudible], Wilcox would attempt
to bring his point to life,
publishing his translations
of passages, short passages, from
Shakespeare Henry IV and Anthony
and Cleopatra into
colloquial Egyptian Arabic.
What follows these translations
is an Arabic language discussion
of hydraulic engineering by an
Egyptian that appears to bear
out Wilcox correlation
of lived language
to scientific ingenuity were it
not for the inconvenient fact
that that discussion
is forma written Arabic
as was Wilcox's original call
for the use of the colloquial
as a language of science.
Paradoxically, the language of
empirical science is often at odds
with its philosophical premises.
Empiricist discourse
privileges matter over mind.
Indeed, it insists
that direct observation
of matter should decide
human axioms about nature
and in effect make up our minds.
Yet, it couches its findings in
standards languages very often
that occupy an abstract relation,
these of the daily texture
of material reality.
In using formal Arabic to
[inaudible] empiricism,
Wilcox brings home a bacon he
surely meant to leave behind
for although opposed bacon as an
exemplar of vernacular ingenuity,
Bacon wrote his "Nuevo [foreign
language] "New Organin,"
1620 in Latin, not English,
and the same problem,
in fact, afflicts Dalte.
He has to write his apology for
Tuscan in Latin in effect in order
to make it reach a wide audience.
Wilcox's essay struck a cord
with epistemic anxieties
of the 19th century Arabic
speaking intellectuals.
Writing 1893 in his periodical, "El
[foreign language]," "The Teacher,
whose pages up to that point
did often did feature articles
in the Egyptian colloquial, the
Egyptian nationalist, Adbul Nadeem,
debunks Wilcox's assumption that
written Arabic is not up to the task
of modern science or
modernity, itself.
How could Wilcox allege that
formal Arabic had stalled Egyptian
capacities for scientific
invention, he opines,
when renaissance Europe had taken
much of its science from Arabic?
Moreover, even modern Egyptians,
who have learned European languages,
and Nadeem writes, "still
use Arabic as a language
of intellectual production
writing books, newspapers,
and stories of their own as well
as translating European
scientific text into Arabic.
Twelve years earlier in 1881 issue
of his first weekly [foreign
language] which can translate
as raillery and reproach and Nadeem
writing in the long wake of the 1798
to 1801 French occupation
of Egypt and on the eve
of the 1882 British occupation,
perceived the seduction of French
and English in the shadow
of European imperialism.
In an essay titled,
[foreign language],
"The loss of language is a
surrender of the self," he warned
against the abandonment of Arabic,
taking the form of an open letter,
the essay's salutation reads,
[foreign language], literally oh you
who pronounce the letter dalth
[phonetically spelled], meaning "oh,
you, who speaks the
language of the dalth,"
which is a common epithet
for Arabic.
With that direct address
to his reader,
Nadeem signals the uniqueness of
Arabic, hence its incomparable,
or at least its non-exchangeability
but invoking the consonant "dalth,"
the hard "d" sound, said to
occur in no other language.
The letter opens with a series
of impassioned interrogations.
"For what do you exchange
your language?
What is comparable to it?
for whom do you abandon it when
you are its guardian, grantor?
What have you found so beautiful
in other language and so ugly
in its analogic features?
I ask you to swear by
God, have you found
in the modern languages what your
ancient language encompasses?
When you express something
with a word
from a language besides your own
and then wish to elaborate on it
with another expression, do you find
even one synonym for it as you find
in your language a cluster of
synonyms for any given word?
Are you the one ignorant of
the power of your language?"
What Europeans like Raunov regarded
as a feature alongside its
unwritten short vowels,
that makes Arabic incomparably
defective, namely the abundance
of words that express the same idea,
is what makes Arabic
for Nadeem rich.
That would then Arabic
lie infinite possibilities
for exchange is precisely
and paradoxically
for him what should inhibit, if not
prohibit, its speakers and writers
from exchanging Arabic
for other languages.
And Nadeem recognizes, however,
why his Arabic language
readership has come
to compare its language with others.
He understands that his
readership judges the currency,
the modernity of a written language
by its proximity to living to speech
and thus is tempted to
exchange a dead, ancient Arabic
for live modern languages.
Yet the threat of the foreign,
and in the case for Nadeem,
the foreign is deeply
linked to colonialism--
he was an anticolonial nationalist,
fighting the British occupation
as well as involved in
anti-Turkish agitation.
Yet the threat of the
foreign, and Nadeem counters,
has historically what has
divided written from spoke Arabic
and Arabic secure in its
power need not reject speech.
it is the failure of Arabic,
historical and contemporary,
to ward off the intrusion of
foreign words on its grammar
that gradually separated, he argues,
the Arabic of the pen from that
of the tongue, making its pages
defensive, and I quote from Nadeem,
"I do not prohibit you from
other languages besides your own,
rather I wish only to remind you
that your language was once spoke
[foreign language] without the study
of a manuscript, without a book.
With the intermixing of the foreign
word, it was somewhat corrupted.
It feared of its loss.
It was recorded in
the bowels of pages.
Its power remained in writing until
its foreign words grew so numerous
that writers opted for these.
Then foreign words multiplied, such
that it, the original language,
was exchanged for a
conventional language,
the word is [foreign language],
language born of usage,
that followed no grammatical rule.
The catastrophe has grown.
Writers have crowned
the transformation
by speaking the colloquial with long
expression, a third which is foreign
to both its original and
its conventional languages."
Notice that Nadeem positions Arabic
in historical cycles of corruption
by an incorporation of the
foreign, here in original Arabic
in which the spoken and the
written coincide give way,
thanks to the intrusion of foreign
words to a conventional Arabic
that is no longer pure enough to
obey rules but operates instead
as a hybrid language whose
correctness can be determined
presumably only by contingent usage.
That Arabic, in turn, has given way
to a loose colloquialized writing
so replete with foreign
words, in his estimation,
that it transgresses
even convention.
Respecting, we might say,
neither statutory nor common law,
this Arabic has broken
with all pasts.
Nadeem's polemic provoked
a powerful rejoinder
from Amin Shamil [phonetically
spelled],
the Cyril Lebanese publisher of the
journal [foreign language] writes
or law, writing within the
month in Nadeem's newspaper,
so [foreign language], Shamil
challenged the vitality
of formal written Arabic.
For Shamil, that Arabic
increasingly lacked a market,
even among its native speakers.
The conjunction of imperialism
and global capitalism drives
his suggestion that speakers
of Arabic abandon their language,
at least as a language of writing
and embrace French or
English as the lengua Franca
of imperial power,
capital, and modernity.
Insisting that "language is
but a material instrument
in which the exchange of ideas
and meaning is transacted
between human individuals,"
Shamil premises the life
or death of language on history.
Understood neither his continuum nor
a cycle as a Nadeem would have it
but as rises and falls that are
the upshot of material causes,
contingencies of power and money.
In as much as language is for
Shamil only an instrument [foreign
language], it "Holds
no precedence as such.
Its might and the decline the
status are rather the outcome
of the attributes of its
people, power and weakness."
Language, he writes and "A mirror
in which the self images
of its people shatter."
Rather than represent the
position and the power of a people
in the world, language
refracted that position
through material filters
of political power and
scientific progress.
Rather than a one-to-one
reflection, you have a refraction.
Absent power and progress, the
capacity to compare or compete
with the modern and to convey the
modern, no beauty or eloquence,
Shamil argues, can save a language.
Languages die, he might say,
naturally with the decline
of the people who use
them and rightly so.
In this fate, he suggests
Arabic will join [inaudible],
Greek and Latin, languages whose
long canonicity, hence, survival,
makes them "more closely
resemble the living
and the image of the dead."
Shamil now assumes in
reverse the empiricist posture
of the young William Jones.
He advises Nadeem and his ilk
to undertake an experiment
and to observe what they see,
to place Arabic literature
in a purely material comparison with
foreign, read European literatures,
and witness the shattering of,
in every sense, Arabic's currency
and I quote, "Go to
our lending libraries
and our mercantile centers,"
Shamil writes, "and see how much
in Arabic," which he calls [foreign
language] so uses the letter "dalth"
to signify Arabic, "see how
much a book in Arabic rents
for versus how much a book
in a foreign language,"
which he calls [inaudible]
softy sound, "rents for.
Then write a book entirely in
Arabic, spend your whole life on it
and offer it to your
people and you will see
that there is no market
for your goods."
Shamil attributes the
decline of Arabic in modernity
to its exceptional-ism to precisely
the sort of incomparability Nadeem
in shrines in the letter
"dalth," that hard "d" sound said
to occur in no other language.
To pronounce the letter
"dalth," is to interdict
or to forbid the comparability and
thus the exchangeability of Arabic
and to declare that the no
language can adequately compensate
for another.
"To enter the world
of commodity exchange
of the profitable production
and consumption of knowledge,"
Shamil intermits, "Arabs
should go the way of the world,
the letter [inaudible], the
ubiquitin soft "d" sounds
that Arabic shares
with other languages
and that makes Arabic almost
at the molecular level
of the phoneme comparable.
Oddly recalling Vulni and
Raunak, as well as Jones,
this vernacular turn again
hinges on the letter.
Yet by accenting the consonants,
not the vowel, as the locust,
both of Arabic incomparability
to date
and its modern potential
to be comparable.
Shamil's literary comparativism
on this point, like in Nadeem's,
which equally accents a
consonants, also reverses
and subverts the terms
of European scholarship.
In Nadeem's essay of 1893,
correlates Wilcox's call
on Egyptians to write in the
vernacular, this is later essay
of 1893, correlates Wilcox's
call on Egyptians to write
in the vernacular, which Shamil's
earlier call on Arabic speakers
to write in foreign languages.
He sees both as calls to
abandon literary Arabic.
Against Wilcox and
Shamil, Nadeem writes,
"The correct language is the
living, given its use by the wise
of the community," and he is
referring to by "correct language,"
to the formal language,
formal Arabic, "is the living,
given its use by the wise of
the community, elite or common
and the colloquial language
or the vernacular is the dead,
give its disuse for
all but the necessities
that a language, less
animal requires."
It's quite a statement.
Speech exiled from grammar, which
is not always tandem out to writing,
but is often fixed and secured
through writing is speech exiled
from the past, and
the historicity is
for a Nadeem the ultimate
corruption, collapsing the human
into the nonhuman animal.
The life he imputes to
correct Arabic rests
in its continuity with the past.
Its capacity is culture
barer and barer of belief.
Its capacity to carry time for
all who use it across Christian,
Muslim and Jewish lines
in this particular context
and to carry belief across
time for Muslim in particular
since former Arabic is structurally
speaking the language of the Quran.
The dialectal is dead because it
is presentence more easily divorced
from the long historical continuity
of Arabic-Islamic tradition
that it changes with the
moment is born out by the fact
that foreign words
compose 1/3 of its lexicon.
Yet a Nadeem makes it clear that
he is not opposed to the influence
of the foreign on Arabic; 19th
century Arabic writers, after all,
have successfully translated
many European language works
into standard.
His point is that formal Arabic
is adequate to the foreign
and responsible to the self,
a language into which modernity is
translatable even as it preserves
and reinvigorates,
so called, tradition.
For Nadeem [inaudible],
Shamil called to abandon the
incomparable language of the "dalth"
for a more easily language
of the "del" is
by Arabic terms [foreign language]
in [inaudible] is a distortion
that the level of the letter, which
in Arabic is [foreign language],
they share one roof, of Arabic's
potential to be worldly, be modern
and at the same time be itself.
"Lift demands artifice, the
formal preservation of writing,
of continuity to brave death."
I shift here toward a conclusion,
moving in a different vein.
In 1899, Saleem [inaudible], a
Cyril Lebanese portrait artist,
resident in Cairo, -- Skip ahead.
This is one of the portraits
that [inaudible] painted --
received a U.S. patent
for new Arabic typefaces
for typewriters for
printing presses.
In his application,
[inaudible] argued
that his invention had reconstructed
and reduced to a mere 58 character,
the 638 different characters
required to represent the 29 letters
of the Arabic alphabet in the
relative positions to other letter,
initial, medial, terminal,
stand-alone.
By 1904, typewriters featuring
[inaudible] keyboard were in use
in Cairo [inaudible]
as well as by Turkish
and Persian officials right here in
Washington and [inaudible] traveled
to the United States
for an extended period
to promote their mass production.
In 15 of May of 1904 issue
of the major periodical,
[foreign language],
"The Crescent" published
in Cairo [inaudible]'s Arabic
typewriter features prominently an
unsigned article detailing his
invention, presumably penned
by the [foreign language],
argues that mechanized writing,
faster and clear than handwriting
has become in "European nations
and the rest of the
civilized world."
There's a strong accent on
"civilization" in his piece.
On 21, August 1904,
"The New York Times,"
in turn published an
unsigned interview
with [inaudible] trumpeting
his invention thus.
"An artist inventor
from Mount Lebanon,
Salim [inaudible] new alphabet
and typewrite will facilitate
study of oriental literature."
Conjoining the languages
and capitalism,
the Times praises [inaudible] for
having conquered the complexity
of the Arabic alphabet and
reduced it to the requirements
of a business office, more to
the point of my lecture today,
it conflates two kinds of Arabic
letters, the Arabic alphabet
and Arabic literature, and imagines
that the simplified
machine translation
of the Arabic alphabet will
extract oriental literature
from the obscurity to which its
alphabetic complexity supposedly has
doomed it and make it
accessible to the world,
presumably by permitting
its mass production
and circulation to wider leadership.
I quote from this article, "The
whole world will be enabled
to know the wonders of
oriental literature,
which has been hitherto impossible,
except in a very slight
degree to scholars.
Even a foreigner, who has
merely dipped into the subject
of oriental literature, knows of
their wonderfulness and luxuriance.
The difficulty of research
will be rendered far less.
The peculiar bulk and complexity
of the Arabic alphabet have made
the riches of these literature
as inaccessible as unmind gems."
Seen through the eyes
of its U.S. observers,
[inaudible]'s invention
takes us back
to the 18th century
of Jones and Vulni.
Jones struggled to make the wealth
[foreign language] was his term
of oriental literatures
accessible to European readers
by simplifying Persian
letters, first translating words
into the plainest French,
then transliterating sounds
into Roman script, into
an assimilated script.
Vulni complains that Arabic failed
to paint its words faithfully,
that is failed to visually represent
all of its sounds to the letter.
He, too, sought to simplify
Arabic, Persian and Turkish
by devising a Roman script
that would articulate
their hidden sounds.
By the end of the 19th
century, thanks to the invention
of [inaudible], a painter, no less,
modern Arabic print culture would
heed the silent song of simplicity;
yet, it would do so
in a different key.
[Inaudible] adapted the structural
logic of the Arabic to that
of the languages of imperial Europe,
that is he reconstructed a script,
whose letters articulate
movement, changing shape
with the relative position within a
word to behave as much as possible
like the isolated letters of
printed English or French.
Yet the Arabic of his new
century caligraph, like the Arabic
of thinkers is diversion
as Nadeem and Shamil,
did not give the consonant, the hard
letter, as the mediating principle
between the past and
future of Arabic
or between Arabic and
other language.
[Inaudible] Arabic keyboard seem
to resist the obligatory marking
of short vowels, Vulni
and Raunak so desired.
His patent application specifies
no keys for those characters.
In a new century that reiterates
the simplification of Arabic
as a condition of its entry
into world literary space,
Arabic unwritten short vowels,
which continue to rely speech,
vocalized in the mind's ear to sound
their hidden movements mark a large
and enduring difference
from a common ground still
overdetermined by western norm.
In that difference, like other
such differences in the world,
a revolutionary theory
of transcontinental
comparative literature,
one that no longer
centers Euro-U.S. paradigms
but embraces polycentrism must hear.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you very much.
Yeah, I [inaudible]
I missed somebody.
[ Inaudible ]
Sure, absolutely.
Right.
[ Inaudible ]
That's an excellent.
Vulni really struggles with this
question in his "Simpificacion,"
he asked to [inaudible]
at various points
that European languages are not
necessarily anymore rational
in their ways of rendering
sounds in alphabetic form
and while he doesn't always
touch French, his own language,
which after all has silent
letters and other such oddities,
if you will, that cannot
be reconciled,
he does point out that there
are numerous failures also
of transcription in European
languages and so part
of that argument goes into
inform his larger interest
in a purely rational
universal alphabet
that will somehow eliminate all
uncertainties of pronunciation
across tongues, but oriental
languages are still, nonetheless,
singled out as being particular
defective for their tendency not
to mark short vowels,
which, after all decide
in many cases not just the
pronunciation of the word,
but also its meaning, you know
the difference between two words
in Arabic with the same consonantal
structure hinges very often
on how the short vowels,
marked or not are read, right?
So this becomes a particular problem
for Vulni but it also is a test case
for a larger attempt to
rationalize script systems.
So, no, you're absolutely
right and Arabic critics
of the impulse towards
vernacular-ization someone
like Abdul Nadeem points out, "Well,
English language scientific text,"
he says are not written
in the same register
of language as spoken English."
That there are differences
in register in the languages
of text too, and so he tries
to poke holes in what he sees
as the false claims of Wilcox,
for instance, that a language
that approximates that of daily
life is somehow a necessity
for scientific invention,
ingenuity, the production
of scientific literature.
He recognizes that
argument as tendencious.
Nonetheless, it also worried.
It worries intellectuals
like Nadeem.
It worries his contemporaries.
They are concerned that
Arabic may lack the currency
to somehow convey the modern
and they are, in various ways,
approaching the question of language
reform from that space of anxiety.
So, yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
Yeah, that's a very good question.
Initially, it seems to have
been manufactured in --
it may have been manufactured
in the Middle East
because there were machines said
to be fabricated in handsome white
and gold but don't look like the new
century caligraph in circulation,
the [foreign language] of Egypt at
the time [inaudible] II owned one,
the Sultan of the Ottoman
empire, [inaudible] II owned one.
All the departments of
the Egyptian government,
which at that time was a colonial
government under the British,
kind of a loose colonial structure
under Cromer, owned one and all
of these departments
were using the system.
Apparently, when he came to the
states, he came under the Egests
of his financier, Ismael
[inaudible], who was the grand mason
of the, basically, chapter, the
masonic lodge of Cairo at the time
and self the descendant of
a Ottoman Turkish notable
and Ismael [inaudible] had
financed [inaudible]'s trip
and also financed the larger scale
manufacture of these typewriter
and he came to the U.S. to seek
basically a corporate partnership
to take this invention
to a much larger scale,
and so the American Writing Machine
Company new caligraph typewriter was
very popular in this first
decade of the 20th century
and Arabic keyboard appears
to have been one such.
Yeah, it's very interesting.
So, yeah, he was here about 18
months promoting the invention
and connecting with
factories in the U.S.
[ Inaudible ]
Thank you.
Yeah, that's a really
wonderful question.
Thank you.
I think you may have been
referring to Shamil from 1881,
who basically calls for
the abandonment of Arabic
on the argument that Arabic now
lacks a market even among its native
speakers, right -- the
Arabic language text,
I should say, lack a market, yeah.
Absolutely, you're right.
There is a kind of an
attention to audience there.
It's a specific sort of audience.
First of all, it presumes
a literate audience.
It presumes an audience
literate in English and French,
the dominate European languages
that would have been read
in greater Syria at that time or
Egypt at the time, so when somebody
like Shamil says, "We should be
writing in foreign languages,"
meaning larger, we should be
writing in English and French,
he's speaking about a very
specific, largely, elite, by elite,
I'm speaking somewhat loosely, you
have an emerging [foreign language],
you have an emerging middle class,
but in a certain sense an elite
who had been educating at European
institutions and Europeans schools
and who are reading these languages.
There are problems right there with
a particular conception of audience
and [inaudible] too is
thinking about audience.
Some of his articles prior to
Wilcox's [inaudible] were published
in the Egyptian colloquial.
This is by somebody who's
arguing against the vernacular.
Why did he do this?
He saw Egyptian colloquial
as effectively a kind of set
of training wheels that would
enable a less literate population,
no wholly illiterate because it's a
slice of population, in this case,
Egypt, "The Journal"
circulated elsewhere
in the Arabic-speaking world but it
was deeply Egyptian in some ways.
A slice of the population who
at least were conversant enough
with the Arabic alphabet
and grammatical system
that they could even read colloquial
Arabic transposed into written form
and he saw it as a stepping stone
toward learning formal Arabic.
So these question of audience
are there and they're there
with the Europeans writers too.
I mean Jones is trying to
think about how to make Arabic
and Persian, and Turkish poetry
appeal to a French audience.
So you are right that one of the
things I'm trying to do is move
across scales to move from
this very odd, seemingly odd,
fascination with something as
microcosmic as the grapheme
or the phoneme, this minutest
unit of language as a sphere
in which comparability is
transacted between writers, thinkers
and the readers to ever widening
circles, so things like form
or [inaudible], or the sensibility
of literature are also
implicated here.
Text that I didn't touch on on this
talk that speaks to yet another leap
in this particular discussion, and
yet another leap in this history
of transaction, if you will,
of comparability between Arabic
and European literature
is one from 1902 to 1904.
Its' first serialized and then
published as a monograph in 1904
by the Ottoman Palestinian
intellectual, [inaudible],
and it's a history of the
discipline of literature,
the science of literature
among the French and the Arabs.
[Inaudible] says, well, I'm
writing this history basically
for an audience effectively composed
of the semi-literate products
of schools in the orient, modeled
on a European paradigm, right,
and it seems pejorative in a way
but [inaudible] is extrapolating
from that audience to a theory
and a kind of a new language
and literature that argues that
tries to resurrect old arguments
from 10 centuries earlier in
the Arabic-Islamic tradition
and say eloquence resides
in the average word,
in the word that reaches the
widest possible public --
widest possible audience, that
reaches the elites and the commons
or the masses alike, and so
there's an attempt to hit a midpoint
in language and then to hit also a
midpoint in literary sensibility.
So there's, you could say,
a revolutionary political
project there on the one hand
but it's also a project that
assimilates Arabic language
and literature to some of the ideas
that we heard today in that --
now, I'm just starting
to speculate widely --
in that he is interested a language
-- his notion of clear language
or transparent language is one in
which word and idea correlate very,
very tightly, so one word to
one idea, and here you start
to hear shades of [inaudible], who
apart from his obsession, you know,
with the question of the
vowel is also very concerned
with the abundance of words with
polysemy of Arabic and argues
that a more developed
language is more analytical,
one word corresponds to one idea;
a language like Arabic is synthetic
or complex and that is
a defect for Raunak.
That is a sign that it has not
actually progressed in the way
that other languages have
and so there's something
of a counter evolutionary paradigm
if we think of biological evolution
as a progression from a simpler
to a more complex organism,
there's an odd reversal of that
evolutional trajectory even
as these theorists are talking about
forms of life, where Arabic has
to simplify, and so in that
sense, the middle word,
the middle register is revolutionary
and yet also in some ways imperial.
So that's the beginning of an
answer to your wonderful question
about audience and how it
inflicts arguments in these texts.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you all again.
[ Applause ]